I get a feeling there's gonna be a riot
I don't be this because can you hear me
can you hear me should we start over I'm
good now so you could hear me now okay
sounds like it's gonna be a [ __ ]
but I'm cool with that because it's been
a [ __ ] kind of weekend hi
everybody welcome to save space i
appreciate listening the people who've
stuck with me through this it's only
going to grow I appreciate it i hope
your december is going well I hope your
week went well I have fun week myself um
tomorrow night we're going to do the
first-ever tin foil hat podcast with
Eddie Bravo that's at seven-thirty
should be interesting I'll get into that
little later but right now I just want
to check in with Erin Erin how are you
I'm good great you look like it
something's going on like the weirdest
like I feel like I'm Heisenberg this is
breaking bad and like the mix might be
going bad with you and you're kind of
freaking out my wife's about to board a
plane to Africa oh really yeah yeah so
you're freaking out I'm not freaking out
I'm just like I just got back from LAX
so oh you just dropped her off yeah yeah
so how long she'll be gone for eight
days eight day so you're just gonna be
doing porn you're gonna be maybe smoking
some weed sure maybe going on some chat
rooms getting dangerous a little bit
yeah yeah I'm hand gonna be what's being
a grown ass man to you Aaron what's that
I don't I don't know what's like your
meat I'm probably just eat whatever the
[ __ ] I want oh just go nuts strombolis
what is
yeah buffalo wild wings yeah probably
more fast food you like that why she
doesn't like to eat the fast food she's
always cook stew no she's just like you
shouldn't do that cuz you'll die and I'm
like oh that's so nice of her yeah she
wants you to be around as long as
possible yeah yeah that would be very
wise of her but so you dropped her off
and as soon as you left did you do any
kind of like like like air celebrations
like boom boom boom guns of the air a
little like did you point everybody
around you know did you robot I don't
think it's good to do air guns at LAX oh
that one oh that's true so there was no
like little mini nothing you don't loan
cuz you always love to be but just a
little you time I get plenty of me time
is your wife out all the time no she
just works later so a little time by
yourself sneak so we go home you watch a
little porn and then you clear your your
history if necessary I like that maybe
she's cool to like you like ah thank you
everybody for listening i know some time
I've been yelled out my youtube page by
the way check out my youtube page ah
youtube.com backslash Sam Tripoli i'm
uploading something every day sometimes
i get a lot of hits and for me a lot of
hits a couple hundred at this moment and
sometimes i get like 30 should i be
defeated no so that's how that's how it
just starts right that's how you build
okay so i'm not bad but one guy i like i
like to do just a update on how bad the
traffic is and it's just getting crazy
out I just yeah don't you feel like in
LA for you to live in LA I know this
might be born but just stay with me I
feel like there's something weirds about
that there's a weird energy in the town
yeah like everywhere you turn something
weirds going on like first of all the
Star Wars premiere after everybody's
traffic up right i mean if you guys
don't know Star Wars had their movie
premiere the new Star Wars coming out
and what they did is a shut down
Hollywood Boulevard okay now wherever
you live imagine they just took the most
popular street and shut it down and now
traffic has to go around it's chaos it
is it is literally
a domino effect from there it's quite I
keep I I said [ __ ] I just want run for
mayor and do all that [ __ ] down by the
staple center you could March your dance
you could sing you'd they have
starfighters on Hollywood Boulevard
right now oh yeah the literal like
starfighters TIE fighter they're called
Tie Fighters yeah wahoo twin ion engine
whoa damn are you excited about the new
Star Wars yeah yeah I am I don't know
when I'll see it but I don't know if you
do see it I I'm ask you if you're a fan
if you're a friend if you're anything
please let me know if it's just a remake
it's a prequel it can't be a remake well
what what about the UH what about the
last one don't tell me that wasn't a
remake it was exact same thing I let's
go up a bigger Death Star let's
literally do the same thing we did in
the Oval and I get it it wasn't that for
kids but it's like that weren't around
when the originals came out yeah that
was one of the first movies ever saw my
grandma took me to drive through I'm one
saw it and I get it but just time to
disney for sure was like doing that but
getting some shady [ __ ] going up but
there was enough new in there to love I
think as a fan no cat I'm cool way
better than the first those three
prequels she doctor strange no I haven't
dude it's so good yeah I want you have
to see it at set the bar really freaking
high really for anyways so they're the
premier shuts on that which means
traffic is horrible yeah so when
something like I don't know where you
live the listeners yeah if I said hey
man let's go let's say you're liking my
hometown 20,000 people right if they say
hey man I live 10 minutes away that
drive is literally about 10 minutes it's
like now came a little less a little
more a little more no one's going 60
through the city ok but we'll say it's
gonna be I have five miles 10 minutes
yeah yeah okay in LA if something says
it's 10 miles away it could take a good
hour hour and a half to get there yeah
like is that crazy 35 on a good day a
good
yeah at four in the morning yeah like
it's just crazy and now did you see this
new thing this do you see this guy on a
sunset you guys might see this video i
posted on punch-drunk a guy jumped on
top a bus got naked and for about half
an hour fingered his but I didn't see
that part day his finger himself he's
just fingering his butt and the cops are
just sitting there going there was a
time we could just shoot him and I'm not
for police brutality at all but you're
[ __ ] my traffic up could beanbag that
guy she'd be back that dude yeah I think
that's fair we're using cook concussion
grenades and [ __ ] laws to go to him I
think a guy fingering his butt on the
top of a [ __ ] transit bus that's a
good that's what concussion grenades are
meant for and it was rad saw the comedy
store right it was just a half a block
down yeah just tell him there's no p'nai
incoming juicy it literally looks like
boom shakalaka was right around just
fisting his paw he's look at these cops
are just like oh my god now tebow should
use that to go viral what fingers bite
up there and just fingers but yeah I
always check I always thought the two
chicks with one cup that there PA person
really missed out yeah we didn't get to
know their names swinging its know you
could have taught them people would have
gone and seen that somebody would have
gone seen up at least like an Olympic
style bio first video of them I uh I i
I've I mean the energy in this town is
weird you hear about TJ Miller yeah yeah
just punching some uber driver and
supposedly i think you might have
punched a couple people now about Trump
maybe you know I say that [ __ ] yeah yeah
I'm totally cool dad it's not good to
see a working alcoholic I'm so tired of
the clean and sober people and I know
I'm sober but I aint [ __ ] I'm by clean
I mean like you know corporate it's good
to see like people with flaws working
also you just can't you can't get in
someone's face about who they voted for
or whatever on either side ya can't get
in their face one hundred percent in an
aggressive way and not you should
popped I'm glad he did it and I'm glad
he gets drunk eating host [ __ ] weird
kind of uh uh uh tech awards and he
makes fun of Asians in it drunk office I
love it I want more TJ Miller's yeah
that's what the seventh of the the
sixties and seventies were all about
everybody loves at that time of
entertainment cuz they were people
they're real people they'd flaws people
have flaws and that's the whole thing
man look at the people out I think
Hollywood is becoming so much like
Washington DC where you have a bunch of
people who are full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
telling putting out this fake image that
isn't really them and that's my whole
thing now I'm not gonna get into it if
they at the core I got the conspiracy
podcast mouth but there is a really good
argument that the the the progressive
left is very much like the religious
right of the 90s and early 2000s this
believing in this higher idealistic
dogma that that they apply to others but
don't live themselves and they simply
just use it to take out people they
don't like and they don't apply it to
anybody you know I'm same here it's like
Patton Oswalt's bit about how like like
Midwesterners hate gays but they love
cirque du soleil it's like dude you know
it's like you if you really hate all
gays you would boycott Cirque du Soleil
yeah you gaze and Russians you can't
hate him if you like sick to select yeah
exactly you can't do that and that's the
same thing with the far super left it's
like that you can't get mad at people
saying something when you're celebrating
Louis CK is the greatest comedian out
there and he has little jokes where he
says everywhere you hate and tells you
no I'm saying it because I really mean
that word and you're like oh my God he's
so good at pointing out the now did its
plot that's why I like him that's real
[ __ ] entertainers are normal people
they're completely flawed they see the
world different show me a normal person
i'll show you a not entertaining human
being yeah it's just the truth and them
if they're in Hollywood they I mean
there's a couple normal people to people
that i can tell you I've met through the
years there are normal
beings and that's Maz Jobrani and Duane
Perkins those are the only two normal
people I've ever met and I'm sure if I
hung out with them long I hung out with
my long time but I really hung out with
him he be you find some crazy [ __ ] going
on you know everybody's got crazy
everyone does crazy [ __ ] when the door
[ __ ] closes me too dude I like my
[ __ ] weird I get weird someday I'm gonna
get into what like I like to do and it's
really [ __ ] weird but I want to take
this moment before i get into everything
i want to apologize to the mcdonalds on
highland between phone and santa monica
boulevard know if you're not from LA
this mean anything you but just giving
Aaron a little reference I wanna
apologize for clogging your toilet and
not telling you they'll figure it out
yeah but I felt really bad which one
would they have multiple stalls or just
the one well they have multiple urinals
in one stall that's see that's wrong
well the problem was it's like I I just
went on a little run where I had like
three nights row where I just [ __ ] in
the mcdonalds who and I didn't want to
just you ever had that quit Ahmad cab
now I'm in lands on it yeah my cat my
cat comment yeah I think just the
problem in Hollywood is like there's no
public bathrooms because there's so many
heroin junkies shooting drugs that they
don't let anybody use the bathrooms
they've literally like during the early
two thousand you couldn't find a public
bathroom the junkies had ruined
everything yeah so I'm like I gotta
mudcat look of a daylight and I'm just
like freaking the [ __ ] out and I'm
holding on you ever hold on where you're
like hold on and it's just like your
[ __ ] quivering cuz it just wants go
boom but you're like I can't [ __ ] in
these jeans in my car this is my brand
new car if I [ __ ] in this car I will
never get that stink out yeah for the
rest your life friends are just like
somebody should their pants like I just
keep driving you know so i sees
mcdonalds i pull in i run in and boom
there's like three [ __ ] right there
and a couple hot chicks and I'm like
heck I use the bathroom he thinks a
[ __ ] saying that the train just bought
some hamburgers he's like yeah just use
it she's like I didn't say it and I'm
like I did I run to the back but it's
like Mudcat time it's like there's no
time it's like my joke is like there's
no time for formalities like when you
use a public bathroom you
love to like put our picnic right you
like they'll put out your picnic blanket
all that's a no time for that dude it is
jumping dump time dude so I jump in and
boom I just hits the toilet and then I
feel something I feel [ __ ] the water
on my ass and I look down and it's
[ __ ] clock and I'm like [ __ ] and I go
to get up but I looked out to see its
Collier I go get and I see there's
motion sensors dude oh that shit's gonna
yeah if I move this thing's can all over
flood so I'm having this weird [ __ ] saw
moment oh man I think I so listen leaf
11 to Bryan is that it if he gets off
thats exactly if I get off the toilet
it's gonna be poop water all through
McDonald's so I have to make a decision
so I get up and i'm just like [ __ ] it i
just i i do my business I get up and I
just run i start to see [ __ ] overflow
I run out and I why yell something but
it's nothing but hot chicks at the cook
at the counter and I'm like dude you
can't I can't cock-block myself I never
know when I might run by these chicks
I'll be single and be like hey honey but
oh you're the guy who [ __ ] clogged
the toilet McDonald's so I freaked out
and I run in my car right I run to my
car and I'm like okay I'm just gonna
yell through the drive-thru window I go
I look out the line is around the block
to go through the XM it's like 11 at
night I'm like [ __ ] dude i know what i'm
going to and i drive by and I just Paul
Revere it by the drive thru I'm just
like my god that toilets are clogged
toilets are clogged I here to reverse
the tire God and then I run off and I
just I feel really bad for everybody at
that that that McDonald number two if by
sea yup never to just I'm ever feel bad
for the [ __ ] that's just probably
won't go in there and shoot math or
something I feel bad so as that was my
story um
Oh chill that's a live we're live laugh
um so like I said the other day what do
I want to get into we are in 15 minutes
in this think God that one fast okay ah
like you said tomorrow night is the
first-ever tin foil hat podcast my guess
will be Eddie Bravo um it's crazy dude I
don't know if I want to do it I'm a
little nervous because people get so
angry at when you put out something they
don't agree with and it's just like I
can talk politics with anybody I love to
debate but some people it's just like
you're dead to me you're dead to the
family you're dead to everybody and what
I've learned is because you know how
this whole thing would like the CIA's
come out now say map but they haven't
said anything it's just an anonymous
source said the CAA has found something
no evidence given but everybody's
running with it it just let me know that
there's it's not bottle conspiracy
theory it's about whether or not it fits
your narrative yeah if it fits your
narrative you believe it there are
emails saying this isn't this about
Hillary Clinton don't believe it one
anonymous source says something and all
of a sudden it's just boom we're running
with it and it's just like it just blows
my [ __ ] mind that people will shoot
down a conspiracy with a conspiracy and
don't give her I I mean I Gaby I hate
Trump dude I [ __ ] hate this guy I
mean he's putting together into Kevin of
the worst the worse is they he's like
Lex Luthor going to super Max's and just
releasing villains like River you're in
charge of Education joka you're in
charge of arts and entertainment Bill
Cosby you're in charge of Planned
Parenthood you know just like going
around getting the worse the worse and
there's no one to blame except for
[ __ ] Hillary and I I don't get too
much in but I'm just blown the [ __ ] away
there's also the American people to boo
him for voting for him they could have
gone third-party they could have gotten
third party I did they like the CIA
might blow it up and they might have to
have another
actually I'm fine with that I'm fine
with that but you gotta let Bernie run
you gotta let Bernie rod if you let
Bernie run I'm fine with another another
one right okay oh so recently uh so I
notice in sports but so tomorrow night
is then we're gonna go live we'll be at
the hall things County Studio 7 30
pacific standard time tin foil hat an
hour of conspiracy talk but i don't want
to be like [ __ ] infowars you know i
don't want to be yelling and screaming I
just want to have fun with it because i
think it's [ __ ] hilarious I've been
you know I got Tebow who I love with all
my [ __ ] heart but that guy on every
podcast just calls me [ __ ] crazy
conspiracy theorist guy and then he goes
heard you see that Oliver Stone ah
Netflix special thing that he did yeah
it's crazy it's all stuff you gotta say
I can't believe it when i watch i was
blown away I'm like why do you believe
him cuz it's on netflix it was on HBO
before that but but why cuz it's on HBO
and by the way think they'd have better
standards then certain certain things
the network that brings you game of
thrones right I was I get that also i er
but that's also the network that made
John Oliver do a hatchet piece i'm
[ __ ] third party candidates and had
[ __ ] John Oliver just lay in Edward
Snowden about why would he do give out
the things he put life's in danger it's
like that was so weird when it happened
I was like what are you doing Jon
Stewart and then Bill Maher's most
interesting version of it because he
just racked on anybody who didn't want
to support Hillary and then he just put
out a tweet couple min a couple days ago
in which he's like I saw Hillary speech
thank you clean for your 30 years of
service and now I never want to hear
from you again it's like that is a hard
turn the opposite way from a guy was
just telling everybody that if they
don't vote for Clinton they're [ __ ]
fascist racist scumbag pigs and now
you're telling never show up again yeah
it's very interesting very odd which
lets you know that it just came from the
top
I mean Bill Simmons got canceled I
talked to people who worked on it
they're like he got notes from HBO and
he didn't want to implement them and I
don't you know they'll tell you what
they want you to say and if you don't
say you're gonna be gone take that John
from Cincinnati speaking of sports i
went to the clipper game clippers vs
thunder i got a call from a friend of
mine clip cast to my favorite people on
the plan Mike Jacqueline and Christopher
Wilde who is literally him and get if I
could do a podcast with him and Gareth
Reynolds I would be the happiest human
be online I would just sit there and
laugh the whole time they're the two
fastest guys I've ever met my life
they're lethal yeah so they called me
and the deal is I go to the pot I go to
the game I get to go backstage I get to
go behind the scenes I get to go to the
locker i'll get to sniff some digs I get
to sniff some dicks and by the way in
the clip Barack room dicks everywhere
I'm sure just walk right I see [ __ ]
Blake Griffin's I'll [ __ ] orange
sherbert dick everybody's just [ __ ]
hanging out [ __ ] walking around and
then you got chicks there and I like if
I was a woman I'd be the happiest human
being in the world I mean what more is
in your wheelhouse that you want then
genetic super freak millionaires walk
around with their dicks hanging out it's
like the number one thing to go see it's
very uncomfortable for me it's very
uncomfortable but I go because I have to
because that's anyway I get my tickets
so I go to the game and all my favorite
reporters are there I go to the media
break room and I mean and someone goes
jay-z's here I'm like what oh I'm like
[ __ ] jay-z's here and I look up and
he's walking in the bathroom and he's
like [ __ ] lean do good looking lean
I'm like all [ __ ] now when I go with
Jagland Jacqueline's whole thing is I
can't embarrass him around the media
that's his one really tells me don't
bearish me I'm like oh Castle you can't
if you can't even if its opportunities
there and he starts it you can't get
into a skip bayless I can't oh I can't
do it I cannot dude I saw um who's the
[ __ ] guy who used to be on ESPN that
now's on Fox Sports who's there NBA
guide light skinned dude ah [ __ ] ya
donde no the other one uh um the real
religious guy yeah like who's there and
I hate that dude yeah yeah yeah I can't
stand him dude he's [ __ ] homophobic
yeah he saw he's working I'd like I
don't know how you're allowed to why I'm
like I'm not somebody thinks because you
are not politically correct and thought
that you should lose your job yeah
that's like that you publicly lately
yeah i discriminate against a group of
people how are you loud to work like you
can say whatever you want like I think
like Joe partner got the show going I
think black athletes in the NBA don't
try hard I don't think you should be
fired for that no that's just his
statement but when you're like blah it's
abomination of God being a gay and I
don't I think it's [ __ ] you're like
got go 2016 gago do whatever you want
with consenting adults I've said it a
thousand times do whatever you want if
you want to go to a [ __ ] motel six
and [ __ ] put it I'll belt around your
neck and jerk off go do it all I say is
get a spotter that's all I've ever said
get a spotter so when your eyes roll
somebody lift shop that's all I've ever
said so I Christmas art Christmas hace
ya broussard yeah hey boosts our dude oh
I saw him at the NBA Development leagues
and I was just like homophobic well that
did I'm I don't give a [ __ ] man I got
yelled I get law I'll getting so much so
I go there I see jay-z I'm not gonna
embarrass Jack so I go outside the media
room and I wait for him and I'm just
watching much luck here he comes out he
starts walking and I go JC guy get a
quick pic and he does like this weird
like [ __ ] like we're like Brutus bow
and then like this weird brush off and
kept walking so I go what and i go to
take i go i go take picture of this old
dude like who look like the sheriff from
no country for old men go don't even
[ __ ] take a picture
yeah so you know what I think [ __ ] jay-z
I'm cool with that I said who are you
Jay Z the Nets aren't even in town get
out of here yeah you bought a shitty
team you ruined it but the funny thing
about Jay Z's like I love Jay Z's music
I think he put out a lot crap people he
puts out a couple good ones but he puts
out some crap I i like his me you know
who hates jc's music me jay-z oh cuz
everywhere jay-z goes that's all they
start playing like he was at the clipper
gave me show him on the jumbotron
everything New York you know 99 problems
and that's all you hear the rest of
night is jay-z song they must haunt him
i remember when i met the charming guy
and he was like don't squeeze the
charmin and I was like I dude I don't
screw the char migos I don't give a [ __ ]
what you do it to Charmin huh that's
gonna be that's gonna be jay-z's
feelings about his music everywhere he
goes he's like oh my god could you play
some biggie some Tupac some Drake give
me some Drake give me some bad canadian
rapper first we as Canadians are with
comedy they are in the opposite spectrum
of music yeah it's not Nickelback Drake
suck it No suck it yeah I'm over it I
don't like it so I got so jay-z shoots
me down I go with Jags and I go up to
the press or the presser is like at the
top of the Staples Center it's like roof
press box I can almost touch the roof
that's how high we are now there's a
golden rule in press box is you're not
allowed to root which is okay yeah
incredibly hard for me when I'm a
die-hard clipper fan yeah and I just so
you didn't have seats at all you just
were in the press box I was in the press
box oh I got the sick though yeah yeah
yeahs by golly mitad hot dogs oh no it
[ __ ] I think come on dude I mean it's a
give and take yeah yeah I guess that is
that I mean al magicals there he's about
33 feet away from the court that's fine
don't mind me i'm a [ __ ] peasant
I'm [ __ ] sitting in the press box so
we got our asses handed to us anyways I
have to be cheering cuz we're doing rude
well and this little dude next to me he
writes for like yahoo sports like dude
enough with the cheering I'm like why
who's I'm dead are you on the inside
you're telling the young youth like me
guys got hope in his life yeah hope it
is I say I can't [ __ ] root for my
team it's like ridiculous and then and
then J crossover hits like a half-court
shot goes that was a good shot um I
guess so there's a little salt left in
you yeah you're [ __ ] machine juice so
we got blown out in the first quarter
and then we kept up with him rest but
they blew us out so badly in the first
quarter so the Clippers are [ __ ] done
was done everybody wants to trade trade
Blake Griffin now clearly everybody it's
not you know if it's not working I'm
trying to think about what is the name
of the power Ford that just got signed
by santonio last year I was yeah I
wouldn't know ah that guy Spurs forward
is uh who I want to sign I like it I
like to do a trait i like to do a trade
what's his name nope that's not it I'll
find his name people are probably
yelling right now ah oh yeah here it is
LaMarcus Aldridge how about that trait
Blake Griffin for lamarcus aldridge
you're not into it I have no idea you
don't care no okay I've just throwing it
out there I mean I like the idea of him
going to back to Oklahoma for uh that's
too late they should do it for Kevin
Durant yeah that's what they should have
done yeah they should have done it way
before I'm sorry but if your guy doesn't
sign an extension with you early it goes
show they're probably not going to sign
with you if you're a small market they
want [ __ ] out of there yeah don't
sound with them don't don't trade them
off man and you could get you I mean
like do Blake Griffin for Kevin Durant
in that market of Oklahoma is a equal
trade yeah you would have lost your fan
base
you have a because Blake Griffin as much
as I love them and this is a classic
thing with teams I room for an MBA our
number one guy is really a number two
even Chris Paul is a number two he's not
a number one same thing with when I rude
for the Knicks Patrick Ewing as great as
he was was a number two yeah he needed
if they could have paired him with let's
say Dominique Wilkins they wouldn't want
everything you need a guy can get easy
buckets those guys can that's a problem
with the Clippers right now we have no
dude who can get easy buckets no easy
buckets um so sometimes I get like
really like a board and I like to just
go look at random channels on the ah I'm
cable and the weirdest one has got to be
espn3 have you ever watched ESPN three
no espn3 got rid of cable before I think
they came out espn3 is literally only
features sports that were started by
drunk eyes and bars every sport on that
channel is drunk eyes bars darts arm
wrestling you ever watch arm wrestling I
I have I [ __ ] love it yeah I love any
sports where it's basically encouraged
to do drugs you want something everybody
is juiced there's no drug testing on
[ __ ] and do they come out with these
giant gorilla arms with that weird
cro-magnon skull that you get when you
shoot [ __ ] roids yeah where you get
the caveman [ __ ] the Geico caveman look
we got the calcium deposit in your jaw
and in your in your eyebrows you look
like cro-magnon man they come out and
they're just got veins veins where you
could like use map quest to find your
armpit there that [ __ ] big and they
just rip each other's off I can't even
imagine them masturbating it's got to be
just they must get so close to just
ripping their dicks off did you post a
jiff of the women oh yeah the one who's
like her breath stinks she's in her face
yeah yeah she's making all these faces
that's hysterical
I love it yeah I bet she's great in the
sack ah what else is there bowling I
mean bowling is on espn3 that used to be
a two yeah it and it is dude if to Be a
Pro Bowl you must be an alcoholic it is
my brother was the number one bowler in
high schools in New York State the
number-one highschool bowler in New York
State did by the time he's in 8th grades
in his third rehab ok it's like it's
like real you gotta be a lush to play
that sport I mean look at what other
games they got they got they got a poker
bowling gambling all those are all like
either you gotta be high or drunk to
play them you ever see the gaming the
video game guys tell me they're not a
[ __ ] either do the smoking weed and
taking adderall yeah yeah that's an
adderall game right there everybody's on
adderall playing that [ __ ] big gaming
is what is it league of legends uh call
of duty look but the actual oh yeah
league it's called [ __ ] pledge I think
so yeah and like everybody's buying
teams of that like Shaq Mark Cuban
everybody's buying true hey you gotta
admit like money but man I don't get why
I don't think it's easy I think you
gotta like basically give up your life
and play video games about all our the
guys who who buy a team oh yeah oh yeah
Shaq is investing his money right yeah
you know he's trying to get that mobile
money yeah you don't have to understand
it you just put a little down yeah by
big TV guys have have fun by a big
[ __ ] television oh so they play and
you know they're all on adderall and
it's just like it's so fun because what
we're seeing now is some of the some
beats pro sports that literally have the
genetically the worst athletes on the
planet yeah like poker players young pro
gaming players genetic garbage but
they're gonna get so rich that
supermodel ha instagram models are gonna
be banging these guys yeah and we're
gonna ruin all the good genes yeah or
maybe when we put out like win uh
like a black guy bangs a fat white chick
out comes a gorgeous looking kid maybe
that's what's gonna happen a model bangs
a geek it has a good looking like smart
chick I don't know I'm just they're
still pretty white gaming gaming is
still pretty white isn't it yeah or is
there a lot of asian there's a lot of a
like two Asians like that but the thing
about the gaming community the the
League of Legends it's from all over the
world okay like everybody thinks you
have ceased gonna be next to explore I
think that's the next big sport I mean
they they filled the staple center J
that's crazy that's nuts I don't even
what my mom just got me a [ __ ] one of
those Ataris that play all the old games
oh yeah and like i wantsa and i love
that joystick it's just one little bit
boo boo boo boo yep and I'm super stoked
about it but I gave up on that I know
when you had to have a beat like as
we're Edward Scissorhands and had to
play all the [ __ ] buttons and hit
everything yeah I'm shitty it's too much
yeah do you play any video games at all
I by the Batman ones on ps4 yeah cuz I
love those right but I it takes me
forever to beat certain parts if it
takes more than two fingers at a time
guess what dog girls out tom looks like
you can go fight [ __ ] Joker no I'm
[ __ ] rock band Oh katha you're just
like just gonna pornhub it like a
champion no um real quick where I can't
watch any of our shows i gotta gonna do
something else so really go play rock
band I think why did that just [ __ ]
happen I hate when your notes on your
iPhone just goes to delete it and you're
like where the [ __ ] is that weird right
so I want to talk about how this is
controversy right now with dak Prescott
and zekiel Elliot and people are
complaining that the partying too much
and they're worried that they're [ __ ]
gonna ruin everything well one photo
with Johnny Manziel you know draws
concern for sure yeah but dude no sorry
that was the Heisman guy everyone yeah
that guy do you watch that thing no I
heard you watch a Heisman like I do
I just got the kids on you know knocks
man am I an [ __ ] when they didn't
nominate the guy from sdsu the running
back from st she owes or how about the
guy theme in mccaffrey from from Asda
Stanford like he said again the record
for most total yards he has like two bad
games we don't need two guys from
Oklahoma know what do we need two guys
from Oklahoma for so many in the
playoffs playoffs so daggered so it
should like what is the point being a
pro athlete seriously if you can't go
out there buy bottles and bang [ __ ]
and they haven't lost till last night
yeah while it's just a team that has
their number yeah like Kansas City
Chiefs have the Raiders number yeah she
softens duh you know it's like dude
Tesla Lebanon to is pretty [ __ ] good
is anyone saying Derek Carr parties too
much no I say sooo busy loving the Lord
I owe that guy loves the Lord ah that
guy's got Jesus on speed dial under
number one in his phone call Jesus but
say you can't party it's like to say the
history time people have power athletes
a party and they were still de grace
whose concerns a greatest baseball
player of all time favorite babe ruth
there's documentation of him at the 17
trek walking to the bar across the
street from Yankee Stadium buying a
six-pack of beer and going back to the
game the guy ain't like 30 hot dogs a
game yeah the guide larry was Jason
Tebow with a pro baseball career didn't
sleep out of better Leafs know I love
tea boba I mean that's literally what he
was he would party in the middle of the
game they would drink it's ridiculous
dear Bob doc was the pitcher oh yeah I
have Cristiano we're on acid yeah on LSD
I don't know why people didn't let LSD
happen all the time I mean up to be fair
it was against San Diego yeah they sell
these they were really bad yeah they
were brand new they were only five years
old at that point do you think you can
beat anyways
yeah there was an acid there is a
pitcher in baseball in the early 1910s
named rube Waddell he he threw like
4,000 strikeouts but if a fire engine
drove by the stadium he would chase it
what in the in the middle of a game he
would run off the field he would go for
drug and chase it always that he's like
smell especially him but he was like
what rainmana pitching yeah you just
throw fire but yeah do they have a rule
like dude we don't care [ __ ] the plan
orphanage is on fire don't bring the to
the fire truck around us we don't care
if kids are dying in a [ __ ] fire yeah
it's nots unbelievable he's like an
idiot savant yeah yeah not robbed at
least he's great at something yeah you
know oh how about [ __ ] Lauren still
used to smoke crack and sack people yep
he was so high I'm cracky crushed Joe
Theismann's [ __ ] ankle I don't know
why I think you should be able to do
more drugs do more you do all the drugs
write it up man [ __ ] it I think we got
just think we've made everything so safe
that there's too many dumb people around
we should just the only rule should be
don't steal from anybody don't rape
anybody don't murder anybody don't hurt
children after that go for it yeah thin
the hard yeah I'm not a professional
baseball player I don't give a [ __ ] if
they're all juicing I don't who cares on
the watch it was just fake yeah do you
like one to nothing baseball games not
terribly no actually be something we
could vote on yeah should athletes be
able to juice yep do you want a whole
UFC of vandelay Silva's from pride who
were just jacked out on [ __ ] meth and
steroids and he just murdered people
yeah that's what I want yeah it's not me
hello my god they're not gonna live
forever nobody does yeah it's not me
they're getting paid as long as they're
getting paid if you live to a hundred
years old you've probably done nothing
with your life yeah
probably done nothing with your life and
everybody said we can we're like dude we
are just like we're we're just bubble
wrapping everything and like with
political correctness now everybody's
acting like that like their pain and
their suffering is [ __ ] unique like
Ronda Rousey that recently was talking
to after her fight one time she was one
time I thought about killing myself I'm
like one time yeah one time he thought
about that one time I thought about
today during lunch and that's all about
again when I got my coffee one time
suicide i call that tuesday through
sunday i'm constantly waking up this is
how crazy my life is you ever wake up
angry yeah I get my dreams I'm still
[ __ ] taking a beating by life I can't
even have fun festive dreams when I'm
running around banging chicks and living
life in my [ __ ] dream i still owe
people money my girl was like what's
wrong it's like I told this [ __ ]
dragon a thousand dollars I'm all this
[ __ ] dragon a thousand [ __ ] box
I'm taking a beating in my dream I wake
up angry I'll fight everybody poured
Dana's like please calm down my god I'm
mobile it's like almost like I'm running
from Freddy Krueger I'm afraid to go to
bed I'm just saying who gives a [ __ ] so
I'll just loosen the [ __ ] up um okay I
feel like I'm gonna do five more minutes
and get out of here a nice short one get
in get out I want to talk about my night
at Comedy Store I had the foul Brian
Holtzman that is chaos now Brian
Holtzman either absolutely destroyed the
room or actually burns it down there's
no in between sometimes when he has a
and the crowds like him it's literally
like trying to do stand up right after
eight guys bang Jodie Foster on a
pinball machine and like you got come in
to stand up right after that that's
tough here like oh that was a little
weird bahaha what's up a meatloaf and
you're just trying to make this crowd
laughs it's just like are we all going
to jail right it's just hard
so I got there to the store and I didn't
know who I know check but I looked and
I'm there like you're filing halts man
like okay I can follow anybody I'll
[ __ ] foul Holtzman I don't want its
work it's like you know you know I'll
work you just want to go out there and
tee off right so i go there and they're
like Holtzman's going up and he's
crushing he is crushing and I'm like ah
it's gonna be one of those rough one
like when Brian Holtzman kills he can
hit like Joey Diaz level we're just like
it can be unfollow ball but like okay
and they're like and all of a sudden I
see Dave Chappelle roll up oh and
they're like I'm like oh man he's gonna
go next they're like Chappelle's he'll
go after [ __ ] Brian Holtzman I'm like
okay and I kept all gaga are we sure
about this because it's a different
state of mind how you're gonna follow
these guys he's like yeah you do you do
I'm like okay so I'm like okay she felt
you up to meet then all of a sudden Adam
the Booker runs down you gotta go up
next he's introduced yeah I'm like what
he's like gone by like [ __ ] man it's
like it's like there's certain guys you
can't just walk up and fall you've got a
game plan that [ __ ] we're talking like
1985 San Francisco 49ers offense script
your first 18 plays no matter what the
defense has given you your running these
place that's how you certain guys you
got fall I was preparing to follow Dave
Chappelle who I consider one of the
grace ever do it I'm a black belt in
comedy homeboy I'm a black belt I can
kill a room I can flip almost any room
I've been doing it for a long time I'm a
bad man okay but Dave Chappelle's Bruce
Lee yeah Bruce [ __ ] Lee I'm like jet
Li he's Bruce Lee Bruce Lee he's a bad
man it's like so Holtzman's a whole
different [ __ ] thing Holtzman's like
the black guy from The Last Dragon sho
nuff that guy like just [ __ ] raping
and pillaging so I went up and I had a
[ __ ] joke about how he had to leave
so I had to go [ __ ] he has to go and
yell at kids get off his lawn and
BAM so then I because I like to yell and
scream to like a call that's what
Holtzman does so I had to go the
opposite way so I start just whispering
like the yin yang twins hmm oh look at a
sump I mmm and I start pounding them and
they I'm just crushing I crushed it and
then I got to bring up [ __ ] Dave
Chappelle and it was [ __ ] cool as
[ __ ] to bring up the one of the grace
ever do it was fun and then I watched
him crush and that was such a good you
know it's like happy new economy for a
while but I mean bringing up Dave
Chappelle's [ __ ] cool [ __ ] so that's
it I don't know that story was that
great but it was something odd I want to
talk about porn BOTS on facebook and
then we're out of here can we stop with
the porn BOTS on facebook please it's
where my mom is that's where my aunt's
are ya okay I don't need porn BOTS I'm
just so tired of it it's like you up
Instagram you have twitter facebook is
family friends and I know you're a porn
bot when you only have one picture up
yeah what hot chick has one picture of
herself they maybe have one picture of
every day of their life yeah one
pictures go do your lazy porn bot I'm
not gonna addy then you go to you cuz
cuz when a hot chick follows you on
social media you get excited about like
what is this you're like is it real
because hot chicks are like celebrities
either want to be followed by somebody
with a check by their name verified or
super hot chick yeah you're like ok
they're equally fun and exciting so you
go and you look and you're like okay let
this be real and you go down and it's
one [ __ ] picture up you're like can't
do a porn bot I'm on here with my mom no
you lazy ass porn bot pretty sure the
internet and now that Instagram now has
a live feed have you seen that I just
saw today you can go live on it it's
over nobody's gonna listen this podcast
okay listen it's gonna be dude you know
it's gonna be the destruction of Western
civilization [ __ ] twerking videos
just live streaming twerking vide why
would you watch anything else my friend
remember were you here for the you
weren't here yet for the anal
toss girl I wasn't it yeah she's on
Instagram she's telling me how to do
lifee I'm like you're gonna lie fee I'm
like so much forever leaving my house
girls got the hose body ever and she
just does working videos unless is so
nice to be able to make money just doing
that yeah if you think you've got rid of
all the [ __ ] naked chick stuff off
the internet how much lighter wood the
internet be Oh it'd be an emic could be
a not even any maybe anoraks anorexic
count was that a good podcast was this
good yeah we cantle be politics Oh am I
getting to politic tea no no what's a
safe space I'm too grown to know here's
a couple questions aww thank you Sam
Rebecca and I will be doing the dirty
show Jerry toy would love to see you do
your show and see you in vegas for the
avians that's great get Tony on the next
punch rock okay that's great all right
good times that's good times everybody
wants to do the AVM porn stuff now I'm
kind of over it did I'm kind of over the
porn [ __ ] they don't want to do one more
of it and then I'm kind of over it I see
all these guys trying to do the porn
comedy thing and I just want to like do
I want to do scared straight with them
you think I gotta make money you
thinking that I'm axon happen but it's
like hey that's your that's your world
I've just learned that porn is just its
own certain [ __ ] thing yeah its own
thing so that's the show I enjoyed it I
enjoyed it I enjoy it I that was good I
love to know if you guys like this if
you don't like that what you think what
you don't think yes yes I do I love you
guys I know guys this is oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] um I love you guys I love to
hear what you guys think of this podcast
which don't think of it if you like if
you don't like it oh you know give me a
shot let me know let Aaron know let
Aaron know what you think please don't
talk to me really
Aaron do you have a favorite podcast to
do and I'm fine with you don't say it's
mine be honest who's your favorite
podcast to cover Fiat Felipe Esparza no
I don't know I stuff no you can't
totally not say mine any of mine my to
uh I'd I don't know okay I respect I'm
running through it I mean I love the
crab feast that's hard not do they come
in here uh they have their own place now
which is very nice sounds good alright
alright so you like the crab feast what
do you like about the crab feasts I mean
I love Ryan Sickler ease laughs if I
want to I love that guy yeah I'm so
happy to do them well yeah so um yeah so
that is yeah I just want to tell you
guys I love you and that uh I hope you
guys like this tomorrow will be punch
drunk and then I'm gonna do an hour show
with my good friend Eddie Bravo we're
gonna do tin foil hat if you want to
listen the last 50 minutes ago take your
calls 730 p.m. pacific standard time I
love you all god bless y'all and i'll
talk to you soon take care boxes in the
ports are busted all your greatest
thinking that you sinking in the rotten
guts are now in
them but everything to gain